[Música]
a ti
pastor cibernético los saluda paloma
martínez desde nuestros estudios desde
nuestros nuevos estudios
nosotros acá
como llamas cuando uno hace la primera
vez
[Música]
inaugurando el debut en este estudio
para
le presentamos al señor
la bienvenida a todos los que nos están
escuchando que nos están viendo que nos
están acompañando ya sea por facebook
por youtube por el sitio internet radio
canadá internacional puntos
lynette punto sea de hecho en el menú
del programa tenemos varias cosas o
leonardo se están moviendo pero leonardo
si menos les presenta positivas hay que
apretar un botón y abajo el rojo está
muy bien
el segundo nombre no se dice no me gusta
no no se dice porque en realidad fue dar
mi abuela que se llama de esa manera
dijo ese nombre a una de mis nietas
un varoncito
ese segundo nombre
hay un montón de gente
nada más a todos nuestros oyentes estoy
seguro nardo gimeno luis laborda que tal
como escritor como todos está todo en
orden yo tengo cuatro nombres
[Música]
eso sí no 445 nombres de madrina lo
bueno y también tenemos aquí en el
estudio acompañándonos en esta primicia
digamos a maría elena vindel ella es
narradora psicóloga y fundadora de un
grupo en honduras en tegucigalpa en
particular que se llama las lobas le
vamos a conversar contigo cómo está muy
bien aquí nerviosa estrenando me con
ustedes en su estudio también
solamente tres millones puedo decir a mi
mamá que entonces me puede ver después
bueno en el programa de hoy les tenemos
juventud le tenemos les tenemos un poco
es un programa planetario juvenil y con
cuentos también con maría elena así que
comenzamos entonces con la juventud y el
planeta
hola soy daniela garcía pianista
colombiano que vive en montreal trabajo
con los ensambles la ma jin y en la
asamblea lo siento y los invito a vivir
canadá en las américas es café radio
canadá internacional en la web
o no
este viernes 15 de marzo probablemente
leonardo está al tanto pero mucha gente
lo sabe en el mundo porque jóvenes
millones de jóvenes de 40 países y entre
ellos los de unas 40 ciudades
canadienses se están manifestando contra
los cambios climáticos porque los
gobiernos se comprometan a preocuparse
por el planeta a hacer lo que le
corresponde en términos de leyes en
términos de acciones concretas los
estudiantes de las áreas metropolitanas
de canadá están movilizados muchas
escuelas la mayoría de las escuelas
sobre todo secundarias colegios y
universidades universidades están
cerradas porque los niños los jóvenes
hicieron huelga hoy no fueron a la
escuela o por lo menos bloquearon la
entrada de muchas de las de las escuelas
que están en las ciudades de canadá
entonces hablamos de esta mañana con una
de esas chicas es una huelga que está
presentándose desde hace varias semanas
peste es este el evento del 15 de marzo
es un evento mucho más grande aún ella
se llama sofía zapata y es de la escuela
joseph françois
así que los invito a escuchar su voz con
algunas imágenes de las manifestaciones
de las recientes semanas vamos a verla
entonces
yo pienso el eje formuló está implicado
en esta causa hace mucho tiempo y cuando
vimos de que esta muchacha el suecia
comenzó un movimiento tan grande como
todos los viernes también te falta la
escuela para hacer una manifestación
para manifestar pensamos de que era una
buena idea de que nosotros pudiéramos
implicarnos en este movimiento los
jóvenes como ese futuro y que si
nosotros nos comenzamos este movimiento
que no va a comenzar
lo importante yo pienso es de que
queremos que la gente tenga conciencia
lo que hace en el medio ambiente que
merece es la base de todo tener el medio
ambiente no tenemos nada estamos viendo
al gobierno de que tengan nuevas leyes
para proteger el medio ambiente y que
las leyes se cumplan porque siempre
dicen dejaban a este narco por nunca lo
hacen que prefieren que las plazas
lleguen en otras partes como el espectro
leo siempre ponen plata aunque no hay
pero no en el medio ambiente nunca le
ponen
y queremos que se haga un programa a
donde la gente comprenda que deba ser
para el medio ambiente
una participación ciudadana
qué les parece estos jóvenes están
movilizados en grande a millones de
jóvenes ya fuimos jóvenes alguna vez no
fueron a clase
[Música]
fueron a exigir y enseñar a aprender
cómo se enseña había enseñar también una
postura que ya es algún movimiento
importante o sea estos chicos que tienen
entre 12 16 17 x 20 años son los que
con el pecho abierto a las balas de lo
que va a pasar en nuestro pino en
nuestro planeta en los próximos años a
nosotros ahora es como si si si el
cambio climático super importante si se
viene se viene pero evidentemente el
impacto es grandísimo hay algunas
personas que dicen que hay políticos en
eeuu que están tratando de pensar un
proyecto para construir barreras
alrededor de manhattan para que no se
llene de agua cuando empieza a
descongelarse lo en vez de prevenir que
se descongele están pensando en gastar
dinero en hacer una barrera para que no
entre el agua a uno de los lugares más
visitado el mundo si eso es lo que los
niños están diciendo ustedes ya están
como en la etapa de ya solucionamos lo
que lo que ya es inevitable pero que lo
que nosotros queremos es que no avance
más entonces los jóvenes de los niños
están yo vi niños hasta de 11 años
manifestándose en londres en suecia
particularmente entonces yo creo en
australia también estaban muy
movilizados y aquí en montreal
comenzaron a manifestarse desde hace
varias semanas
los viernes y se iban a reunir entonces
me parece maravilloso
escucharlos la que no los políticos no
escuchan a la gente de su edad digamos
tango terráneo si desde su época
como generación internacional que
evidentemente son ellos los que están
dándose cuenta de que esto se está
pudriendo y que no hay forma si uno no
actúa no estaba pensando pero es cierto
es decir cuando se habla de este tipo de
cuestiones
lo primero que aflora es el discurso y
las acciones hasta ahora no son muy
concretas de hecho quienes tienen el
poder de tomar las decisiones desde los
centros de poder parecería ser que no
solamente no les preocupa el cambio
climático sino que además han hecho todo
lo posible por ignorarlo por darle la
espalda
en cualquier lugar del planeta en el que
uno se encuentre ya hay pruebas
suficientes de que el clima está
padeciendo un proceso de transformación
que de no ser modificado y en el corto
plazo muy rápidamente va a tener
consecuencias muy graves tal vez no para
nosotros tal vez no para la generación
que nos siga pero si dentro de dos o
tres generaciones y en el futuro el
planeta como dicen ya han dicho ya en
más de una ocasión los los científicos
podría convertirse en tierra inevitable
entonces movilizarse y reclamar es
apenas el primer paso hacia un cambio
que debería darse ya ayer pero pero lo
interesante es que ahora la movilización
parte de la migración
generalmente la que recibe y la que no
habla siempre están diciendo que los
jóvenes son el futuro por una parte pero
que no participan coeficiente que nos
implican suficiente ni en las elecciones
ni en cosas tal vez están proponiendo
una manera diferente de hacer las cosas
entonces veamos cómo evoluciona seguro
que va a evolucionar de otra manera
imagino que en honduras también hay
movimientos juveniles que se están
moviendo aunque no sé si me quiera decir
algo
como dudosa si yo no yo creo que
honduras dentro de los países que no
hacen nada desde los primeros que no
hacen el gobierno el gobierno en
particular y la empresa privada en
particular no les conviene hacer nada
porque entonces te afecta a tu economía
a nivel industrial entonces calle monos
no digamos nada pero veremos yo creo que
esa es la cultura general en general
porque evidentemente si lo hace bueno va
a tener problemas increíbles desde el
punto de vista monetario y los demás
países yo creo que hacen exactamente lo
mismo o sea es cuidar su economía como
elemento primario y punto de partida y
después veremos qué serán los que vienen
después y ese es el problema
de ver que osea lo positivo es esto lo
que está pasando con los jóvenes lo que
está pasando con estas criaturas que
están tomando el estandarte de la lucha
de debemos hacer algo porque se nos está
pudriendo el planeta o sea eso es lo
positivo lo que se pudre el planeta sino
la salud de estos niños que están
tomando el estandarte de la luz ahora lo
que es cierto es que generalmente
pensamos en que el planeta es el que se
va a destruir el que va a desaparecer
pero creo que somos los seres humanos
los que no sobreviviríamos exactamente
el planeta alguna manera va a encontrar
maneras de adaptarse como lo ha hecho
de los millones y millones de años que
estamos estamos en un país arrollado que
consume materia nunca mejor dicho el
término materia concreta a diestra y
siniestra alcanza con ver cuando se
produce la recolección de residuos en
los distintos municipios la cantidad de
cosas que arroja la gente a la basura
cada semana o cada 15 días según se
trate de los expertos del tipo de
desperdicio que se recoge y
me acuerdo que hace tiempo atrás hace 34
años atrás hubo una discusión sobre el
tema de los envoltorios de los productos
por ejemplo si es cierto que no nos
puede exigirle a la gente que de la
noche a la mañana deje de comprar un
producto que necesita pero cuántas veces
nosotros hemos comprado algo que viene
en envoltorio que duplica en el tamaño
del producto que necesitamos y a veces
con materiales que son difíciles de
procesar es tan difícil lo que hay que
hacer es tomar la decisión y en este
ámbito como en tantos otros en la vida
de las personas tomar la decisión a
veces es el pilar difícil si éste se
tomen el tiempo individualmente porque
si no salís a la calle en tu vida diaria
tenés que la conciencia ecológica y
cuidar de no ser parte de los que
ensucian más pues en casa y composta en
casa
para reciclar todas las llevas la
bolsita plazo para que te escuche
a una persona conocida y reconocida en
el tema que decía que todos estos son lo
más pequeño que sea de parte de la gente
en general vale cuenta lo que pasa es
que habría que lograr que los gobiernos
se den cuenta de que el gesto mayor debe
ser de parte de ellos
y la situación y la situación no es la
situación la peor aquí hace unos meses
atrás estuve visitando tuve la suerte de
visitar túnez y en pleno desierto uno se
encuentra con una cantidad de
desperdicios impresionantes porque
porque los gobiernos no se hacen cargo
de limpiar esos desperdicios entonces
las empresas encargadas de llevarse los
que hacen los trasladan desértica roja
en desierto en el desierto del sahara
uno se encuentra con cantidades enormes
de basura entre ellos kilos toneladas de
bolsas plásticas
nueva york- coincidimos viajes
familiares los dos el mismo fin de
semana
cantidad de basura
pero yo creo que yo vengo de una ciudad
muy poblada la ciudad de mexico y usted
está tú también bienes de bolsa con
niveles de consumo muy por debajo
exactamente eso es lo que cambia creo
porque ahí salía cada noche las bolas
montañas de bolsas de basura en las
esquinas o en las enfrente de los
comercios era increíble cada noche
entonces eso te da la impresión de que
no sé a dónde se está yendo toda esa
basura porque espacio ya no queda tanto
alrededor tampoco entonces dónde están
enviando esas futuras por ejemplo tú
tienes playas donde ya no sabes si es
arena de colores o plástico que se ha
roto
de hecho arena ya he hecho arena como
sea me ha tranquilizado cuando esté
bolivia molido sí por por la erosión
igual está sentada y tú puedes ver las
aves toda la playa y es basura y flota
basura y no te atreves a nadar en eso
porque tú no es como estoy nadando con
la basura ahora ya no es con el numerito
sino con la basura y es una
contaminación de las aguas terribles y
además no viene la basura de guatemala y
de otro sitio tenemos
dónde está el nuevo edificio no es el
nuevo edificio todavía es el 2020 es
nuevo estudio que será el nuevo edificio
que tiene las mismas características lo
que vamos a tener a partir del 2020
joshua landis dice super nice el nuevo
estudio saludos al zamora saludos de
salvatierra saludos desde la tierra
mexico y mal sabor dice acá en
salvatierra guanajuato la movilización
de los jóvenes inicia en media hora
[Música]
gilberto martínez nos está viendo
también el cambio climático dice césar
ya lo estamos sufriendo y no hay que
esperar mucho para ver sus grandes
consecuencias y saludos desde nicaragua
nos dice gilberto así que la gente que
está conectada con nosotros gracias a
todos ellos vamos ahora a hablar así de
frente con maría elena vindel
estamos hablando de estamos hablando de
otras cosas pero podemos entrar de lleno
al tema que usted conoce mejor o que el
que más le gusta en todo caso que es el
de la narración el de los cuentos a mí
me golpea porque en argentina me dice en
argentina maría elena y cuentos es una
asociación muy especial
sobre todo entonces el nombre mar y el
ine cuentos le queda vía social no le
queda bien entonces mariaelena vindel
entonces narradora psicóloga también y
fundadora del movimiento las lobas en
tegucigalpa en honduras está de paso por
montreal por canadá por un tiempo vino
acá por uno
y está organizando un evento del que
hablaremos en un momento más pero me
gustaría que viéramos un vídeo en el que
podemos nos vamos a ver como mientras
hablamos podemos ir lo viendo al mismo
tiempo en el que vemos justamente estas
reuniones que se crean a partir del
movimiento las lobas de qué se trata
este movimiento las lobas en particular
maría elena bueno mira las lobas es un
encuentro de narración oral femenino
verdad porque femenino no porque le
vayamos a tirar duro a los hombres pero
no quiero que en ese escenario lo
hagamos antes pero con los cuentos
entonces el encuentro de las drogas
qué te puedo decir yo soy hondureña
verdad y el arte pues es muy escasa a
nivel educativo y a nivel escénico pues
no tienes muchas opciones y eso me
obligó a salir gracias a dios me obligó
a salir de las fronteras de mi país y
visitar diferentes encuentros festivales
o lugares donde narradores de todo el
mundo se hacían hacían un encuentro no
en mexico en argentina que te decía que
estuve por ahí en paraguay que también
estuve y nicaragua costa rica guatemala
y eso girar por todas partes me hizo
querer hacer esto en mi país y quería
hacerlo distinto a todos los que he
visto verdad y pensé porque no sólo
mujeres porque además somos las que nos
dicen que estamos ligadas estrechamente
a la narración porque somos las que más
hablamos así nos dice no somos la más
chismosa las que contamos las que
decimos la que hablamos la que nos
recordamos de hace 8.000 años lo que nos
hiciste la última vez entonces yo dije
bueno vamos a jugar un poco con eso pero
además quiero empoderar
la diversión desde el entretenimiento y
desde el empoderamiento y empoderamiento
positivo no confrontativo no pelea no
discordia no darle duro al hombre porque
no estoy de acuerdo con eso tampoco pero
si crear un escenario donde los cuentos
tengan algo interesante que decir de las
mujeres de antes y de ahora y entonces
se me ocurrió el encuentro de narradoras
las lobas con esa intención hacer una
convocatoria a nivel internacional y
quienes quieran venir que vengan y les
doy lineamientos muy básicos no que
tengan cuentos eróticos cuentos
satíricos leyendas reales de mujeres
reales porque y eso me pasó porque
cuando fui a colombia en un encuentro me
pedían una leyenda de mi país y yo solo
me sabía la de la llorona porque el
marido lo dejo o la de la cegua que mata
a todos los hombres infieles y hoy estás
esos cuentos me ofenden como mujer y
además me ofenden como realidad cuando
tenemos tantas leyendas vivas que han
dejado un legado y pueden ser un cuento
perfecto para
a futuras generaciones para hacer un
cambio en las mujeres y su
comportamiento porque tenemos por
ejemplo mi país yo no sé si ustedes
conocen a berta cáceres un ambientalista
que fue asesinada eso es un cuento real
porque ahora dicen los lencas que se
escucha la risa de berta en las aguas
del río huancarqui y que ahora es ella
parte de los espíritus que cuide el río
eso es un puente o maravillosa las hijas
de bertrand leñas estudian acompañando
aquí es que hubo en otros programas y
fue gracias a ver está a esa muerte que
yo nunca me imaginé que se atrevían a
nacer porque ella era tan fuerte que
dije nunca se van a atrever a matarla y
a ella la mataron entonces cuando yo vi
eso dije sí a ver está la mataron porque
no nos van a matar a todas porque además
mi país está considerado uno de los
países con el mayor porcentaje de
feminicidios a nivel mundial casi
epidemia proporcionalmente claro cada 23
horas hay un la muerte de una mujer no
hablemos ya del abuso de la violación
que es una muerte pero es una muerte en
vida no conozco las otras estadísticas
en américa latina pero sé que en mexico
por lo menos son 10 mujeres por día que
mueren sin otra y honduras está
considerado imagen de smith m es una
epidemia por una cantidad exorbitante de
femicidios en un mes y medio han mediado
mujeres que no toma conciencia de actos
de violencia y que antes no eran
considerados como tales y ahora sí se
los reconoce
nosotros no somos tan grandes como para
no poder recordar cuando en nuestra
niñez se hablaba con mucha más
frecuencia de lo que se habla hoy en día
tapado o no de que un hombre le había
pegado una mujer y eso no era visto como
una falta en un delito hoy en día no sé
si todo el mundo lo caracteriza como un
delito pero estoy muy seguro de que en
la mayoría de los ámbitos cuando alguien
cuenta que le pegó a una mujer muy mal
no va a recibir ningún aplauso por lo
menos va a haber alguien que se va a
expresar algo al respecto fernández las
sociedades donde éstas están pobladas de
instituciones que están realmente
regidas de manera muy patriarcal mehsud
el idioma las iglesias las religiones es
mundial y eso está cambiando está
cambiando lentamente y a fuerza de
enterarnos de que estas cosas pasan a
diario entonces bueno eso va cambiando y
eso es importante yo creo que este tipo
de manifestaciones también ayudan
exactamente podemos decir a la gente que
nos está siguiendo ahora que con que
comenten cómo ven la realidad de las
mujeres en sus países porque hay gente
de todo de toda américa latina
particularmente que nos están siguiendo
entonces si continuamos haciendo de este
proyecto entonces esa fue mi intención
y ahí nació ese es mi porque además como
arte terapeuta conozco las bondades del
cuento y sé que es una herramienta muy
útil para nuestros países que tienen
amordazado el poder decir algo verdad
entonces o que tienen prohibido o negado
o ni siquiera pensamos en cómo poder
decir algo entonces me pareció que he
peleado mucho un país me he dado duro
con muchas cosas en mi país antes fui
presentadora de televisión y
presentadora de radio y después del
golpe de estado pues se me cerraron las
puertas porque mis temas pues ahora
obviamente eran en contra del golpe de
estado y eso me obligó a hacer
cuentacuentos porque me tuve que salir
de mi país y aparecieron los cuentos lo
empecé a utilizar como algo artístico
que a mí me gustaba y vi la potencia y
vi lo fuerte y lo bonito y lo bondadoso
que es el poder hacer esto y después me
empecé a interesar en el arte terapia ya
como un plan remedial alterno a la
psicología tradicional porque eso de
sentarte y que te duela y que te pica y
llorar
mejor te pongo a pintar a jugar y vemos
qué hacemos con eso porque eso también
el arte es una herramienta muy poderosa
al nivel emocional que muchos ignoramos
entonces por esa necesidad por esas
ganas y por esa búsqueda de cómo sonamos
en mi país fue que yo hice este
encuentro y fue muy bueno porque a pesar
de que el año pasado en el año pasado
fue mi primer edición y justo eso fue
noviembre y en octubre si no me equivoco
se hace lo del éxodo de los migrantes de
honduras que salen a bares y a mares y
me llamaron narradoras que ya tenían su
boleto comprado migenes que no vamos a
ir porque es que además de ahí nos matan
fácil no entonces yo dije yo continué
con mi proyecto pero si se me bajaron 3
perdí narradoras orales que se que se
fueron en esa caravana se fueron en esa
caravana y no les pude decir
porque tenían razón le estoy invitando a
venir a uno de los países más peligrosos
donde no mata más fácil pues te
garantizo que te puedo proteger porque
además tampoco es tan selva como se mira
desde afuera pero con este éxodo yo que
les voy a decir además no se sabía que
venía después de eso la verdad entonces
afortunadamente hubieron valientes que
me dijeron confiamos en ti y confiamos
que nos vas a proteger y además queremos
ir a aportar a este país porque justo
por esto queremos ir y canadá en todo
esto después de todos esos viajes por
otros lugares como se inserta canadá en
el proyecto porque los que nos dijo son
la mayoría de habla hispana entonces son
hables y estamos en canadá y aunque hay
algunos sabemos varios que hablamos de
pánico pues mira la verdad es que yo amo
mucho el español es una lengua que me
parece de las más románticas y de las
más complejas y amplias que tenemos y
amo que sea mi lengua natal y estar aquí
con tanto frío
porque los latinos en pleno
eran con saludos uno dice johnny y willy
navarro de salud ser 6 canadá en las
américas aquí desde lima estamos en
plena marcha por el medio ambiente que
se realiza en el centro la ciudad
asimismo se está planeando cuidar y
preservar las lomas de la ciudad en
alianza con una universidad privada
jon wiley navarro y se desarrolla de
chardin dice muy bien mejores cámaras
mejores manejos de planos dice
informaciones entre los entrevistados
manejo iluminación escenario buenos
avances y el tema que las lobas griten
fuerte sus historias
[Música]
y este año por eso queríamos hacerlo
nuevamente porque vi el resultado es
impresionante yo no sé si ustedes han
tenido la oportunidad de ver caritas
cuando ven algo nuevo y ver y yo estaba
más fijándome en en el público que en
las narradoras no y yo tenía la
oportunidad de verles las caras y eran
caras tan maravillosamente sorprendidas
caras educadas que nunca habían visto un
cuentacuentos y decían eso existe
esto es técnica este es tu trabajo te da
de comer
medio medio pero me da de comer pero es
lo que yo amo verdad y yo dije lo vuelvo
a hacer lo vuelvo a hacer porque porque
fue muy bueno el resultado en mi país y
creo que este año se están sumando a mas
narradoras más empresas me están
queriendo apoyar así que eso a mí me ha
eso me hace ver que no andamos mal ya
que hay invitaciones también y zamora
dice a ver si pueden programar las lobas
una visita a salvatierra méxico pues
puede irse la loba
porque mi primera función y surge por
eso también el nombre porque mi primera
función como narradora después de que me
sacan que me sacó por el golpe de estado
y me voy a costa rica y yo sigo buscando
dentro de la televisión algún trabajo
aparece un taller de cuentos me va a
servir la sangre y llamó a mi maestro y
le digo
porque es que yo puedo contar con tu
piel y que guste y el primer libro que
yo tenía en mis manos se llama las
mujeres que corren con lobos de clarissa
pinkola estés lo empecé a leer que
además como psicóloga es un libro que
todo el mundo debe leer y entonces lo
empecé a leer y empezaron a aparecer
cuentos
yo dije este mí esto es esta es mi
primera función entonces mi primer
función se llama la loba que es la que
voy a hacer aquí en canadá cuando
estamos todavía cuadrando pero estamos
entre el 4 de abril y hay dos opciones
de hacer dos funciones más el 9 y el 14
y el 16 ya nos tendrá que enviar la
información para que podamos informar
pero es la idea hacer la loba aquí en
honduras y si vamos a méjico voy a
llevar a la luz
y entrar en contacto con lo local exacto
voy a ir a la lobby convoca de la luz de
hecho en guatemala me dijeron hagamos
las drogas guatemala y encontrar y que
hagamos la loca costa rica y dijo que se
están queriendo sumar porque de verdad
es un movimiento que ha causado mucho
interés entonces lo que sucede es que
hay
porque las cosas no salen de ningún lado
el interés de la gente no viven en
ninguna parte viene de algún lugar muy
específicas y exactamente hay una
necesidad de abrir la voz y de contar
nuestras historias como mujeres
empoderadas no no no realmente me
interesa me parece súper interesante y
sería interesante también que se genere
en esto está loba en este caso por el
nombre tan particular pero este tipo de
movimientos que gracias a los cuentos
gracias a la literatura gracias a la
posibilidad de comunicar bueno me
entregan a la gente que le hace falta a
este mensaje un mensaje tan importante
de empoderamiento de cambios un mensaje
de cambio que hace falta que está porque
está golpeado porque uno lo ve todos los
días y como la mujer sigue resistiendo y
como estas sociedades
reiterando patriarcales
oprimen y ahora quizás un poquito más
tapado porque no está tan bien visto que
es un gran paso pero que haya elementos
que puedan hacer surgir este poder y
esta y esta esencia de la mujer no y
tocando el tema que tú estás diciendo mi
interés también si es verdad que nos
hace falta mucho camino pero sí es
verdad que hemos caminado un montón y
que ha habido mujeres que nos han hecho
la brecha para hacerlo entonces este
encuentro más allá de victimizar o de
hablar de las víctimas que somos es
tratando de enseñarles lo que ya no
somos y enseñarles lo que hemos logrado
hasta ahora porque hay cuentos que nos
cuentan la historia desde cuando no
existía esta capacidad de hablar de la
mujer no podíamos hablar no podíamos
votar nos ponían casi calzón de castidad
y nos han ido y nos han clavado de bruja
nos han comentado de todas formas mental
emocional y física y sexual verdad
entonces si hay que tocar este tema para
empoderar pero también para reconocer
porque hemos reconocido yo soy una
generación que gracias a las mujeres que
estuve antes puedo estar aquí parada
contigo pude estudiar y tengo la
capacidad de defenderme porque me siento
empoderada claro yo víctima víctima así
lo siento lo vivo lo conozco lo vuelo
pero en mi vida real que un hombre me
ataque a mí personalmente en cualquier
área ya no es tan fácil porque ya no ya
no todo mi ser todo mi haber no te lo va
a permitir y creo que ya somos mucha
sección el mundo pero también creo que
hay movilizaciones ya tal vez los medios
sociales las redes sociales tengan algo
que ver en eso también porque hay
movimientos a veces uno le echa mucha
tierra a las redes sociales de los los
impactos negativos que pueden tener en
la vida de las personas de los
individuos pero en términos globales las
redes sociales han jugado un rol
importante en porque yo creo que si nos
estamos movilizando también la gente se
está movilizando a diferentes niveles
los jóvenes que les presentamos hace un
momento comenzaron también por ahí y por
qué sino cómo hubieran llegado a la
información si no es a través de esas
redes que no son solamente las redes
los grandes medios que presentan sino
también las redes a partir de la gente y
lo mismo pasa con las mujeres las
mujeres también nos comunicamos por ahí
y nos puede servir de justo de vía en
este momento mismo estamos en facebook
live y si no estuviéramos en facebook lo
que está live perdón lo que estamos
diciendo no no todo el mundo puede estar
escuchando entonces bueno es una es una
parte y el movimiento yo también me to
ese es un movimiento que del que se
habla mucho pero que tiene
ramificaciones una de las ramificaciones
más clara es la que estábamos y ya que
estaba mencionando es un momento la
cuestión sexual y recientemente hablamos
de en un sondeo en las canadienses en el
día de la mujer la semana pasada una de
todas las mujeres que nadie se conocen
por lo menos una persona que ha vivido
alguna agresión sexual de algún tipo
entonces es decir la situación es grave
pero creo que a través de esa rama se
puede ir a otros lados otro tipo de
empoderamiento también si por ejemplo en
la universidad de riverside en
california
yo fui invitada
yo tengo una pieza que yo escribí y es
se llama disturbio narrativo y son
relatos cortos reales de mujeres niñas y
de niños que fueron abusados y que ahora
son adultos y que tienen secuelas en su
vida actual
entonces ese tema como psicóloga ha sido
algo que me ha interesado muchísimo
desde el inicio desde que lo estudie
porque porque es muy común y a mí me
pareció algo muy interesante cuando
estoy en la sala terminó la función
porque además entienda en el nombre de
disturbio narrativo imagínense lo que es
no entonces se levanta un hombre muy
alterado y me dice por qué hace esto
cuál es el punto de hacer esto y era lo
primero que pensé en esta pregunta y
chanfle ahora que le digo no y entonces
yo mientras me decía yo soy saco piensa
piensa homero yo dije ok ya está y le
dije hagamos un ejercicio
quiero que levanten la mano cuántas
personas conocen directamente ya sea en
su cuerpo o en su familia o en otras
personas allegadas a ustedes el abuso
sexual infantil levantaron creo que 100
personas en una sala de 300
cuando la levantaron en los ángeles yo
me sorprendí porque no me lo esperaba yo
dije 34 10 100 y el dentro de los que
levantaron la mano entonces yo le dije
mira a tu alrededor
esto es lo que no se habla y si nadie lo
hace lo hago yo porque tengo la
herramienta de la narrativa para hacerlo
porque tengo la psicología que me ha
dado todas estas historias para crear
cuentos para que ustedes los escuchen
porque lo hice a nivel de estadística
sin síntomas pronósticos entonces
simplemente cuadre agrupe vi los
síntomas las secuelas y crear un cuento
de a partir de estas situaciones y esta
pieza es una pieza bastante fuerte que a
mí de hecho tengo que quedarme en el
conversatorio para para que no nos
salgamos así todos distorsionados pero
es muy importante porque lo que yo les
decía es la denuncia que tú no haces
porque es tu tío que amas y si tú lo
denuncias va preso y te cae la familia
entonces al final eres tú
el porcentaje es un 90 por ciento de los
abusos sexuales a niños y niñas y las
secuelas de adultos son terribles es muy
difícil repararse bueno loba muchas
gracias
manuel hernández muchas gracias por
acompañarnos se vaya todavía tenemos que
leer algunos mensajitos que nos han
llegado en las últimas semanas sobre los
temas anteriores pero un placer tenerla
para tenerte por acá maría elena dende
narradora psicóloga y fundadora del
movimiento las lobas en tegucigalpa en
honduras gracias gracias a usted
tiré de jung woo chicos tus tenemos
entonces al castor citó cibernético el
castor ciclo cibernético que va a leer
los mensajitos tienen cortitos porque ya
saben cómo somos que se tiene que sacar
los lentes
ya que estamos hablando de una ración
tengo uno está referido en español y los
adultos mayores en canadá 10 sur 2
molina que nos dice todos somos
inmigrantes nos lo indica la historia
con países cuyas ciudades llevan nombres
como esposas 9 etc
excelente artículo muy interesante nos
dice zurdo molina sobre el tema y el
español y los adultos mayores en canadá
ya que tengo un mensaje recuperando la
sonrisa es un programa de artistas
canadienses para mujeres marginales
maría desde panamá nos dice en lo que
pasa es que tengo dice dos dientes
solamente a la parte delantera no sé
cómo hacer tendrá este problema de
haneda muchísima pena necesito que me
ayuden en verdad soy una joven de 28
años madre soltera y tengo un problema
con clientes en la parte delantera y me
da vergüenza
me faltan los dientes y no sé qué hacer
para en este caso para maría que vive en
panamá le decimos que este programa
particularmente es un programa que está
dedicado a la gente canadiense el sitio
de internet no está la dirección pero
nosotros hemos hecho porque hace rato
está publicado este tema una pequeña
investigación y hay programas en
distintas ciudades importantes de
distintos países que tienen como fin
quizás no exactamente lo mismo pero sí a
toda la gente que nos tiene para poder
hacerse tratamientos entonces la
recomendación es buscar en panamá si hay
algún programa que tenga las mismas
características que el programa que
estamos con sugerir ponerlo bien tengo
aquí un comentario sobre el tema la
defensa de los derechos humanos y los
proyectos extractivistas canadienses en
colombia y paola gómez pregunta de hecho
es una pregunta la que hace que podemos
hacer los ciudadanos canadienses que
vivimos en canadá para ayudar bueno
generalmente lo que se recomienda cuando
uno es canadiense y cuando uno tiene
acceso a su diputado
es escribirle una carta al diputado
porque si canadá está implicado en algún
tipo de proyecto pues escriba el
diputado y le explica la situación y le
pide que intervenga y de nuevo entró ir
a verlo directamente todas las
circunscripciones electorales
canadienses tienen una oficina del
diputado que el diputado federal y
diputado local también entonces lo más
por lo que no tiene al menos una jornada
de la semana destinado solamente a
recibir a los vecinos
exactamente entonces paola gómez esa es
una de las opciones para ir para pedir
digo para contribuir a esta situación
que más tiene por ahí yo tengo un
mensaje de corto también falta mano de
obra en las plantas pesqueras del
atlántico canadiense nos lo envía a
carlos betánces y nos dice me gustaría
trabajar en el procesamiento de pescados
y langosta estoy disponible para cuando
ustedes lo deseen y el puesto que me
elijan bueno como decimos siempre tiene
que entrar a la información en
particular aquí seguramente va a
encontrar algún link que le va a brindar
la información oficial al respecto
porque no somos nosotros los que le
vamos a dar el puesto y mucho menos
ojalá
pero que ingresa el artículo que vean el
riesgo si tiene algún link y si no que
se refiera a la página en particular del
ministerio del sector en este caso el
ministerio de pesca debe tener
información también al respecto yo aquí
tengo otro mensaje avance importante
para mejorar la visión de pacientes con
glaucoma me estaba leyendo esto y me
acercaba para ver mejor yo no tengo que
lado como pero veo poco mariah lluvia
amada ya dice buenos días desde colonia
y le escribo mi hija desde los 16 años
de edad le hicieron una cirugía del
glaucoma quisiera poder comunicarme con
ustedes de algunas formas gracias y le
decimos a maría nubia que dentro del
artículo está el nombre de la persona
que fue entrevistada con respecto a este
avance importante habría que ver en tu
universidad trabaja y ver si se puede
comunicar directamente o con el equipo
de investigación que está conteniendo a
esta persona y adalberto correa mejía
comenta el tema el ejército de canadá
levantaría requisito de ciudadanía para
aumentar sus efectivos y él dice cómo
puedo pertenecer al ejército canadiense
siendo colombiano yo estuve siete años
en el ejército colombiano incluido el
servicio militar
y el resto en una brigada móvil en soba
roja quisiera saber qué tengo que hacer
para pertenecer al ejército de canadá
bueno como decimos aquí el requisito que
se deja de lado es el tema de la
ciudadanía pero tiene que ser en canadá
no puede verlos postularse desde
colombia y no lo van a traer de colombia
aquí para que se sume el ejército aquí
tengo otro mensaje del mismo estilo y
salvar a mi hijo jan santana garcía que
dice soy de panamá pero vivo en montreal
soy ciudadano permanente me gustaría
servir militarmente en canadá como puedo
hacer en este caso es mucho más fácil
porque ya es residente permanente
entonces ya tiene un pie adentro y los
requisitos deben ser mínimos en el caso
de la gente que ya está en canadá y
hablando también de trabajos otro
mensaje por acá los camiones sin
conductores llegan a canadá en 2018 y el
impacto será profundo es el tema que
presentamos nosotros y alfonso
ambulancia dice soy un conductor de
camión con licencia bsd
que debe ser muy grande y muy
profesional con la experiencia es un
camión que transporta vídeos con
experiencia de 13 años en una empresa
petrolífera y bueno pues me imagino que
en el reportaje también viven en guinea
ecuatorial
porque recordemos que no sonaban cuando
se habla español es la lengua oficial
una de las lenguas oficiales entonces
alfonso novoa bula azul que nos escribe
desde guinea ecuatorial muchas gracias
alfonso la información se encuentra ahí
directamente en el reportaje se nos está
acabando el arte del tiempo pues tenemos
tener más mensajitos tengo un acuerdo
sobre el tema empleo también porque
canadá quiere traer a mucha gente dice
abundan ofertas del club de industria
canadiense de la marihuana
nos dice hola buenas soy de españa me
encantaría trabajar aprendiendo el
cultivo
se está postulando el compañero bueno no
lo sé realmente fuera de toda broma como
decimos siempre son temas que tienen que
ver sobre todo con la gente que vive en
canadá no no creo que sea posible de
postularse desde exterior aunque es el
tema realmente le interesa que busque la
vía
el accidente canadiense después se
sumará la actividad que haga una
tecnicatura que tenga que ver con la
tecnicatura un técnico en la escuela
técnica que tenga algún tipo de d
del título con respecto a cultivos y ese
tipo de cosas que sea fin para poder
entrar al proceso de migración y después
entrar a canadá es que un empleador
diga que necesita este tipo de empleados
justamente los encuentro aquí luego que
exactamente entonces en este caso es
mucho más fácil entrar pero bueno
siempre se hace a través de un empleador
en particular y de algún tema en
particular es de alguna empresa o sector
en particular
entonces si no a través de las embajadas
ganaderas del proceso como siempre hemos
dicho es la inmigración es es largo las
representaciones de la actitud y existen
muchos países o consulados
de canadá en algunas de las ciudades más
grandes principalmente ahora bueno se
nos está acabando el tiempo creo que ya
nos vamos lo mejor nos vamos 30 segundos
entonces vamos a irnos viendo muchas
gracias madre linda madrileña schindel
nuevamente gracias por haber estado acá
y regrese claro que sí gracias a ustedes
por su tiempo luis laborda mucho gracias
próximo leo negocio - paloma martínez
los saluda y síganos por internet
www.inter.it a la patria
[Música]
a mí